ding-ding same thing welcome back to the
gym Julian podcast we missed you so much
we took last week off for Labor Day we
had a good time we ate food happy
returned to the podcast I know it was a
giant hole in your week that you missed
but we appreciate you letting us take
the week off we are back this episode is
brought to you by post mates who
delivered evoke avocados
to you boy this morning I literally got
avocado some super millennial today
because that means post mates to get a
literally one piece of millennial right
now guys you can get your own avocado to
us delivered right to your front door
with post mates and for a limited time
post mates giving you $100 off free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you sign up down the post made up
and use code Jenna Julian guys save the
hassle get the food delivered to your
door
forget those lines and get your toast
also guys quip it is the new and
improved way to brush your teeth also
like a millennial I guess yeah on theme
guys quip is delivered right to your
door they deliver you refill packs of
bristle heads so your bristle heads
never get dulled to the point where it's
not doing its job so they refill your
stash of that so you're always getting
the best possible brush and it starts
with just $25 if you go to get equip
that's GE t qu IP comm slash and julian
right now you'll get your first refill
pack free with a quick equip electric
toothbrush Thank You quip thank you post
mates you love affordable oral care
afford or o bulk are fedorable care
alright y'all the time has come you've
asked for this like a lot like people
have been asking for this a lot mm-hmm
okay I have so many tiny faces looking
up at me right now guys there's like
three beds in here you gotta go lay down
it's not about you today I'm so sorry
it's about you literally every day but
right now it's not
well Kermit we're going to be doing by
popular demand a birth chart in it so we
what it was the website that you have a
astrology calm we both asked our mothers
what our birth times were and we printed
out a birth chart slow along with a
cobalt compatibility one for both of us
I have my full chart Jenna has her full
chart and we have the compatibility
chart to show you how incompatible we
really are how we fightin against the
odds every day wait so what what time
were you born again I forget 2:30 p.m. I
was born 11:30 a.m. hell yeah
rise and shine but your mom found out
that she was pregnant by being airlifted
by a helicopter yeah [ __ ] so I called my
mom before recording this cuz I wanted
to get like my birth time and she wanted
to tell me the little story but
basically like when she was six weeks
pregnant with me she didn't even know
she was pregnant
the widow she's calling me right now put
her on the podcast
mom I'm podcasting does she is this a
butt-dial hello
20 bucks says it's a butt-dial mom mom
you blown it there we go live birth out
for my mom she does that to me probably
like 10 times a week she was saying when
she she did not know she was pregnant
and then six weeks into being pregnant
with me she was on a cruise ship with my
dad because my dad he did comedy on
cruise ships back then so Lomita and she
had to get airlifted medevacked by a
Coast Guard helicopter off the cruise
ship to another island cuz they were
like in a cruise around the Caribbean
islands to a different Island cuz she
had like a fever and she was really sick
really sick she was like fully sick but
it was because you know being pregnant
and went on mm-hmm
so she gets airlifted and that was like
her you know she likes to always say
like that was how I said hello to her
like that's how she found out rosemary
yeah she got airlift and I spent like
some time too
morning searching because that happened
in 1991 and I was searching and
searching and searching for any sort of
news story about it because she said it
was on the news and I haven't found it
if you want to look well I'll give some
information it was in 1981 it was on
Norwegian cruise liner
it was around Miami in the Caribbean
islands around that area and she was
medevacked because she was pregnant
that's it my mom's name is Lisa so
anyway that's how she found out I was
pregnant but yeah I was born at 11:30 in
the morning and then she texted me the
story of the day I was born
please read that please read it aloud so
we can all enjoy I can't believe she
taught me I woke up at 7:30 a.m. on
April 17th 1990 to turn to your father
and said I had enough of this we're
going to the hospital right now like
Canaries she's a very Aries mother we go
to the hospital turns out I'm already in
labor you were born in 11 36 I was on
epidural epidural so there was no pain
it was like a cocktail party around the
bed your dad's one wish to my parents
was that we'd be left alone and have our
baby immediately my father shows up in
the birth room so my grandfather showed
up anyway that's the story of my birth
but yeah so let's do years all right you
were certainly I'm excited okay so I'm
gonna need some help because I don't
really does it give you the full on yeah
I mean I can read whatever you want but
towards the 15 pages after your chart is
like what what it like they give you a
breakdown so that's where the expertise
comes in from this side cuz I don't know
it says like zodiac drop urine Aries for
if for some reason someone didn't know
Julian Aries um I'm an Aries my birth
son is an Aries wait so when it's his
son is that your birth sign I think so
so like it's their son Aerys my moon is
Scorpio oh I don't know what that means
you gonna have to tell us and my mercury
is Aries my Venus is their mid heavens
Aries is going on I don't know I don't
like I don't know enough about this to
know if like those are supposed to be
something different where it's typical
yeah I feel like this is very much more
complicated than
thought it was that's a Virgo in here if
you go to like the next couple pages you
know that's how they mean so keep going
we're not reading your birth chart today
we should meet their birth charts do you
want us to read your birth chart okay
this birth chart represents for julen I
wrote my name is Dylan the Sun
represents vitality a sense of
individuality and outward shining
creative energy wait wait wait wait wait
time out hold on what are you reading
birth chart wait what part of it the Sun
okay I'm starting with the Sun which is
like your major Sun in Aries that's what
it says right Sun in Aries Aries is the
first sign of the zodiac yeah we know
beavers and Aries are natives sorry I'm
struggling right now are two the first
Aries Natives are the first to start in
the first to finish whatever they set
out to do the ID I identify with that
mm-hmm I like to get things done fast
and I like to be there faster than
everybody what are you doing why are you
flipping through that just read I'm but
I'm gonna finish before you so employ
people with Sun in Aries are direct
straightforward and uncomplicated they
expect the same from others and are
baffled when they don't get it me me me
yeah I mean we know you're an Aries no
but the part where they're baffled when
I don't understand absolutely baffled
the body comes first with Aries Sun and
Aries people are natural athletes at the
very least their natural inclination is
to use their bodies to get things done
super accurate I think they're not given
to long drawn-out emotional moments nor
are they big on planning ahead this is
the story of mine Jenna's relationship
instead they live their lives simply
[Laughter]
that is scalding tea called the
simpleton what is happening right now is
most important Aries impatience is a
definite vice innovation is a huge
strength how do they know all this okay
and I say like that is so true about you
about innovation it's like if Julian's
hungry and he's tornado and he's ready
to go he will invent something delicious
on the fly like you are innovative I
like how my end of my innovation
strength just strikes you immediately in
the kitchen like okay the first thing I
watch you make things that I'm like I
don't know what you're going for but
then you'll be like here may have this
tortilla with just the most random [ __ ]
and it's really good you'll like it
sometimes only sometimes we'll be like
eating the same meal whether it's like a
restaurant or something we've cooked and
she'll look over at me and I've made
like a sandwich out of all three parts
of the meal and taking an individual
fights about yeah and she'll just be
like baffled and I'm like why are you
not doing that you are very innovative
in patience as advice Ares loves
starting anything new and they have
trouble sitting still they are pioneers
in whatever they do and there are very
there is a very basic quality of bravery
in these people that is unmistakable
Ares generally knows what they want and
they know the quickest route to getting
it they take shortcuts if they must but
generally everything is above board what
is above port like it's not boring okay
underhanded just isn't their style some
Wow
what the hell was underhanded like they
do everything full force like they're
not lobbying anything like has no layups
we're [ __ ] why they have to make a
softball joke in here Beach that is that
is actually a mean joke no it's not oh
it's not it's not means I mean sure some
Ares people are bold but even the
quieter ones are brave and even plucky
in their own way independence is their
birthright
sure nothing gets them going more than a
fresh slate the promise of a new day and
a brand new start cool I think this is
all pretty accurate so far let's hear
about your moon and stuff what's next oh
I want to keep this is interesting
homeboy Ares enjoys a challenge and the
Ares son are the happiest when their
lives are moving forward and active
there's a childlike quality to all areas
some people and it's often quite
charming 10 out of 10 is true ladies he
has a strong personality and even an
entrepreneurial spirit he's ambitious
oh that says he because I entered that
my sex was male he is ambitious and
self-willed stubborn obstinate and
tenacious weaknesses nervousness
impulsiveness wastefulness provoking
nature restlessness and change ability
oh my god that is the T provoking nature
all I can think about is you when you
think it's so funny to provoke Kermit
you'll be killing flies and Carman old
like bark because he doesn't like the
way that you're moving in you go just do
it harder
what my poor baby I don't know what
you're talking about I don't know what
that yeah okay Aries ascendant cancer
does not come across as typical areas
you tell us what that what that says and
what that means okay I don't know what
it means it just says Kerry's ascendant
cancer
this is underneath where I was just okay
opposition moon should I go to the moon
no what's your Sun and X sunny net
what's that just read it
all right the urge to work towards a
goal for success and accomplishment and
or for power as part of your makeup you
are uncomfortable in any position in
which you must take orders from someone
else Oh true recognize your ambitions
and your need for authority without
going overboard seek out a career that
allows you to manage rather than be
managed if possible I think I'm doing
the right thing it is crucial that you
accept the part of you that is ambitious
but take pains not to over identify with
that image that is really not you
successful career is guaranteed but may
sometimes come late ok now we're on moon
should I get the moon yeah
what's your moon this is minus 63
opposition Sun Moon you have an internal
struggle between your needs and your
wants you can lack focus and be
indecisive as a result your ability to
be objective is both an asset and a
liability simply because when you just
signed on one route you were pulled in
another direction at the same time see
babe I'm not going in another direction
I'm pulled in another direction well I
think they start getting distracted it's
not my fault it's my moon I understand
thank you just next time it's happening
bugs at you moon is falling me it's a
bad excuse for me ok I'll accept my moon
is pulling me this way I'm going to use
that ok
something tugs at you and you begin to
question your stance but what if and on
the other hand our statements you can't
help but make and that might plague you
but you're always aware of the opposing
point of view and the other side of the
coin the moon represents the emotional
responses unconscious predestination in
the self-image this is moon in Scorpio
while others may find security and
comfort in material things moon in
Scorpio people seek out emotional
intensity no matter what there is
something very intense about lunar
Scorpios they are diggers when it comes
to the world of emotion and they they
can see beyond facades and cut right to
the corporate person ok I can [ __ ]
when I meet someone I can tell a through
that egg right away and I track record
and I can't I'm like what do you talk
about that person was cool and Julia's
like nah dude not and then like six
months later we'll find out I'm like oh
[ __ ] how did you know that I didn't know
that that was something I was good at
until I started to meet scumbags yeah
and remember the first time I met them
expressed it to you yeah and it blows my
mind every time cuz you're right every
time cuz it's not often that you meet
like bad eggs it's not all the time but
like when Julian's like I don't know man
I don't know about that guy and I'm like
what are you talking about he's always
right always that's pretty crazy that is
crazy no matter what there's something
very intense about oh yeah but this
ability to see what isn't obvious to the
rest of the world can be intimidating to
others or
the attractive depending on the audience
there's always a wild via check Wow
while their deep-seated need for
transformation hold on the term
deep-seated mmm-hmm it's like deep
within you like way no but it's spelled
se a te d oh yeah I was deep seeded yeah
I don't know about that I thought it was
SE e de dee wait are we wrong I guess
deep seated mmm it's it's deep in the
auditorium deep-seated need for
transformation and rebirth can manifest
itself in the lives of lunar Scorpios in
different ways most have powerful
emotionally intense lives some feel like
it is beyond their control hmm so okay
so now where do I go because these are
just like more moon in Scorpio should I
skip yeah sure do you wanna hear about
your Moon okay keep reading much a moon
okay okay these natives seem to attract
social upheaval in their lives appear to
consist of plenty of dramatic ups and
downs however when accepted as an
emotional need rebirth and change
doesn't need to be so dramatic and
overwhelming in some way or other moon
in Scorpio native seek out intense
experiences if their lives are regular
in any way there can be an unconscious
need to test their own strength and stir
up emotional excitement self-awareness
and acceptance is probably the best way
to handle this deep need for emotional
drama do you feel like I need emotional
drama in my life no but I do feel like
there are times when you know life is
just sort of going like yesterday we're
just all of a sudden you're like I don't
know why I just like feel kind of down
or like you just like you have these
moments of like you just feel something
you know what I mean yeah but it's not
drama I think maybe if you were a
younger person and like we hadn't met
each other and you were just like out
there really being an Aries I think you
would have more emotional drama mm-hmm
you know yeah because you kind of you're
a good compliment to when I have those
episodes yeah but I mean like I'm also
six years older than you and we
immediately sort of like went into this
hmm we're living together and
everything's pretty calm you know yeah
doing things halfway or having
meaningless relationships simply doesn't
fulfill them
lunar Scorpios want all or nothing moon
in Scorpio people often have a strong
fear of betrayal they seek out
commitment and feel the need for a
partner to give up something for them
some will put the people they love
through a series of tests and these are
not always conscious their apparent
suspicions can be trying for the people
who love them however once committed
moon in Scorpio people can be the most
loyal and protective partners around
even the shy ones have an enormous
presence their lives are emotion driven
yet many moon in Scorpio natives spend a
lot of time controlling and mastering
their emotions their intuition is
enormous although that is sometimes
self-serving that's that's you what did
I put you through tests me not really no
maybe a little bit like subconsciously
maybe yeah yeah just like little stuff
like it's not it's not like ah ah ha got
to be honest I like to you it would be
things like little if I pass the test in
your mind maybe like I think my I think
the only tests I can think of are some
of my best friends like meeting you or
thinking yeah that's what that I yet
moon in Scorpio people radiate strength
even in the absence of experience they
seem to just know things it would be
difficult to shock or scare away lunar
Scorpios in the face of emotional
honestly honesty and power some people
instinctively want to lean on them and
are less brave folk run a little scared
in other less brave folk or a little
scared lunar Scorpios have exceptional
radar that allows them to size up a
situation a person quickly and expertly
again this is like judge of character
thing this ability allows them to
understand human motivation and nature
can be too close for comfort at some
times and enormously in enormous ly
comforting for others so like my ability
to like suss out a situation is
comforting for people around me mm-hmm
me right but when you used to work
security for me it's like really nice to
have you around because you're that
person that just looks at everything and
like you can tell when shit's weird and
when it's not mm-hmm whereas I can't
really always tell because a lot of it
just feels weird to me anyways I like
that
many lunar Scorpios are intelligent and
astute those that use their enormous
powers for intimacy and honesty are the
happiest and they make the most
interesting and rewarding friends and
lovers short description courageous
brave independent not a fearful nature
he is attracted to sensual erotic
partners where did that come from what
wait what that came out of nowhere okay
weaknesses excesses of pleasures of the
flesh okay
KSS though I don't know where that came
from hmm sensual delights and sensuality
difficulty letting go are we reading the
why did you just cut to like pure sex
okay Oh Julie we know you dark secret
some new version is erotic moon in IV I
don't know what that means so I just
read all this should we just like I'm
afraid to bore you I don't want nobody
asked for this okay no moon in IV I
guess these are all my moons right yet
go ahead okay but I'm just trying to
understand that like I haven't actually
really quick all right it's cuz I'm the
cuz they give you a physical trainer
zodiac tropical um moans okay Sun Moon
okay I think that makes sense yeah okay
he likes family life peace and quiet he
likes to stay at home surrounded by
loved ones and agreeable circumstances
strongly influenced by the mother that's
accurate like I'm very much like my mum
you long for a sense of true belonging
but you may be quite Restless in your
search you might change residents
frequently or simply feel the need to
make changes in your home moving
frequently may be a healthy thing if it
keeps you emotionally stimulated but if
you find that you do so on whims and
later regret the changes you might want
to treat it as a symptom of emotional
unrest as a sign that you were in
constant search for the perfect mood in
setting when in fact a feeling of
belonging should be worked on from the
inside out
not the outside and I feel like I'm in
therapy right now some of you might
remain rather immature on an emotional
level never wanting to truly grow up or
take care of yourself attachment to your
past traditions and family are strong
that one just felt like a scolding all
right 89 sextile moon of Jupiter he is
generally pleased and composed dude so
again I'm sorry for the stupid questions
but these are all the possible moons and
I have to find which is mine are they're
all they're all part of your birth chart
okay he's generally pleasantly composed
due to an inner sense of harmony and
emotional balance he's optimistic and
realistically so most of the time which
contributes to his overall look he's
able to get real perspective on
emotional matters that not only benefits
his outlook he's able to offer support
to others when needed broad-mindedness
is a wonderful characteristic quick to
find humor in situations he is generally
warm and fun to be around deep down he
believes the basic goodness of people
and life in general he believes in it
and this basic and natural attitude
helps him attract positive circumstances
and make good connections one of his
best qualities is tolerance usually he
doesn't take life too seriously in the
sense that he believes in having a bit
of fun his hunches are more often than
not bang on more often than not hang on
like I have my hunches are strong yeah
he is frank honest optimistic and
generous he likes a good cooking his
comforts sorry he likes good cooking his
comforts his friendships are sincere he
is a worker and knows how to surround
himself with the right people he is
appreciated at work that's all true
really mm-hmm - 21 square moon lilith
love at first sight is to be avoided as
it will make one forget all other duties
and lead to problems
mercury represents communication
Cartesian and logical spirit mercury in
Aries there we go
he makes quick decisions streamlines
learning and is direct and
straightforward in speech possesses an
innocent charm and can easily motivate
others
his enthusiasm you mean intensity he
loves a heated dispute lovely mind which
quickly understands a given situation he
is a resourceful and capable person
prefers to jump in to sit into decisions
and doesn't have much patience with
pretense I love jumping in this decision
we know that's the best way to make
decisions just jump into them like a big
swimming pool mercury and IX his thirst
for knowledge is never satisfied he is
full of mental activity he undertakes
exhaustive studies
that's mercury in virgo right no IX yeah
IX is 9 Oh
Virgo all he does IV that means Aries
okay so IX is Virgo okay so this is my
Virgo mercury his thirst for knowledge
is never satisfied he's full of mental
activity he undertakes exhaustive
studies always studying for pleasure
likes journeys to faraway places and can
go live abroad last-minute trips you're
eternally curious and hunger for
knowledge you enjoy studying and
learning and do not do it because you
have to but because you want to you
enjoy exchanging ideas and personal
philosophies with others you can be
especially buoyant is to enthusiastic
and even inspiring in your
communications all that's really true
about like literally all of this the
twitch stream like that your love for
camera and stuff like you always learn
for pleasure when it's something that
you enjoy mm-hmm all the time I feel
that mm-hmm let's see while you may not
pay enough attention to details you're
skilled at finding a quick solution to
problems that did that sentences of my
life that is my [ __ ] life I don't pay
any attention to little details I always
find myself in a problem because of it
but I'm quick to solve that problem but
the didn't need to be a problem I just
let it and I'd let it manifest you get
you get off on how information affects
people's lives and you get you take
great pleasure in learning that's
something that you have shared or taught
has inspired others to take action
experience something new or make changes
in their lives
some of you might be too quick to offer
advice however that might be lacking in
therus and practicality or you yourself
don't follow hmm
Venus represents an interest for
emotions and values exchange and sharing
with others Venus in Aries Venus in
Aries people flirt by being upfront
direct and even daring they try to win
you over by expressing how enterprising
and independent they are their style of
expressing love can be maddening
maddeningly me-centered
but in the right but the right person
for them will find this approach
charming what my me centered approach to
wooing you people get turned on by Venus
in Aries or a innocent charm even when
they are being childish and impatient
like you want to be mad at me but you
find it charming again it's really hard
turn-offs include a relationship that is
considered stuffy or to mature vagueness
and beating around the bush in love
Venus and Aries people are hopelessly
addicted to the conquest in order for a
relationship to remain fresh and new to
them they require plenty of stimulation
I'm a newborn baby that's what they're
saying
I need stimulation ok stimulate me I'm
here
pleasing Venus and Aries involves
fueling their need for action be direct
open and honest with them they won't
much like game playing or evasive ness
in less it is their complete spirit of
fun that's true not only campaign feed
their need for spontaneity and
appreciate their playfulness understand
their desire for the relationship to
remain young and fresh
Aries likes to take the lead in love
even if their Sun Sign is a gentle
Pisces let them at least for the most of
the time indulge them in their many
whims and understand that they thrive on
competition even when they are competing
with you a short description wants to
take the lead in love love's the
conquest can be spendthrift with money
is given to making impulsive purchases
likes to keep things exciting love very
ardent spontaneous and charming in his
direct straightforward approach to love
alright so Venus others mine no okay
some Venus in X there is no X is that
mid haven is that Libra I don't know
that that's where X is supposed to be
but it says mid heaven Midheaven
Libra mm-hm
the best years are in the parental huh
home and also are the last years of life
what that said the rest are not unhappy
but contain certain hurdles love can
help in professional life he has a gift
for seduction oh my god likes to
entertain he likes comfort and the
interactions of home life I like being
at home and I like entertaining that's
that good others tend to respect you for
your charming manner and you have many
admirers although some of these admirers
are from afar as there is an aura about
you that is charming yet strangely an
intriguingly distant you have a great
need to be recognized or admired for
your charm beauty or loving manner but
should be careful not to become too
wrapped up and what others think of you
as you might come across as phony or
superficial some people with this
position are married to their work or
their image you are good at making
contacts and organizing social events
okay I mean it I feel like I'm good at
meeting people now that I enjoy it but I
feel like I'd have a natural affinity
for Saturn sextile Venus Saturn he is a
good grasp of reality and up duty he is
thrifty reserved and does not show off
he likes truth and justice in love his
sentiments are sincere and deep he never
plays false he is of course faithful and
love and friendship he can love a much
older person and appreciates his
intelligence and good sense
oh my letter V that's look at me that's
you you are my person and I love you and
you're much older maybe six years older
than me
but all of my friends are all over me
mm-hmm I haven't like maybe two friends
that are my age just keep going whatever
you want you almost get to Mars and
Pisces
okay mild-tempered didn't and gentle
these guys and gals move through their
life in a manner that can hardly be
considered direct Mars is the planet of
action and assertion and Pisces is the
passive sign that rarely asserts itself
in a direct fashion so the placement of
Mars and Pisces is an unusual
combination sometimes prone to feelings
of guilt about their anger and
difficulties with asserting themselves
Mars in Pisces individual individuals
seem to go with the flow this is
certainly not very not a very active
position for Mars and Natives will often
let life happen instead of trying to
control their life direction this is
charming as individuals with Mars and
Pisces don't like they are don't appear
like they are capable of harming a fly
however those who don't find creative
expression for this energy can stir up a
storm through indirect aggression I've
identified with a little bit of that
like not being like if I don't have an
outlet I get frustrated yeah
Mars and IX bergdahl Virgo deeply rooted
opinions which he knows how to defend
energetically at a certain moment of
life he can fight for a particular ideal
but might abandon it along the way being
less convinced then at the beginning of
his virtue or because he realizes that
is a losing battle conflict abroad with
foreign or with foreigners sextile Mars
Uranus he possesses exceptional energy
he is impulsive but bold he takes on
risky enterprises for the good of the
community with all the energy he
possesses he has a great need for
independence like his freedom of action
sextile Mars in Neptune
his feelings are dominated by wisdom and
geared towards the ideal he likes water
sea voyages he likes odd people trying
Mars hell yeah
ascendant Jupiter in Virgo he attracts
the most good fortune when he is helpful
honest orderly and pays attention to
details
the service industries nutrition and
health are prosperous avenues and I've
worked in the service industry practical
and technical knowledge and skills are
most valued a real problem solver and
others appreciate his help doesn't
always feel lucky or ambitious rather
hard work is valued Jupiter and three of
our go
he has good judgment a sense of values
and an open three years Pisces oh you're
says first sorry I was different than
you I was reading off them like they
were a thinman I know that I was
cross-checking mine he has good judgment
a sense of values and open and
optimistic mind a good education and
high moral standards he liked studying
he is successful in communications work
his professional work is a vocation and
plays a great part in his life
Saturn represents concert contraction
and effort Saturday an Aquarius
long-term studies and if family
circumstances do not allow this he will
teach himself he is serious and
methodical and work likes to visit the
elderly and intellectuals who both
enrich his mind hmm let me wrap it up
pretty soon so you can get to hers
mm-hmm house 3 in Virgo
he pulls everything to pieces analyzes
and criticizes overthinking and over
analyzing is a probable a busy early
environment
he is proactive tends to detail and take
care of things in an efficient manner
doesn't take on anything without
examining the pros and cons mmm not very
me right I don't really assess things
like that your personal natal chart
that's my personal note oh yeah I think
that's kind of pretty cool it's kind of
it yeah I really really like reading
that yeah like aside from when you get a
general sort of Aries reading or
whatever yes
it's very specific and it's very true to
you yeah don't yeah son oh okay
Aries and Moon with some solid Aries let
me just read this last bit enjoys a
challenge also appreciates post mates
when they delivered to his front door
using Julian for $100 off the delivery
charges in the first seven days oh
that's interesting
well guys actually if you wanted to use
post mates you can download the app
right now and Ezra Kojima Julian and get
$100 towards free delivery in your first
seven days of using the app postnatal
livers all sorts of restaurants markets
establishments nearby your house or in
your community that might not have
delivery services built-in which is
really nice because that's kind of a
mind-blowing thing about post mates and
that's what got me to them early on is
that I had so many places that I wanted
to go to town but tackle Bell Taco Bell
dude think about that Taco Bell
delivered to your front door you don't
need to sit in that drive-thru you don't
need to get in your car you can sit on
the couch and Taco Bell just comes to
greet you
because post mates is there just
download the app and order 24 hours a
day 365 days a year post mates will
bring you whatever you want within the
hour you can even see where the food is
and track your driver you can text them
you can call them you can add
substitutions there most times just
wonderful and very helpful also post
mates this isn't even in the copy but
they do some really cool activations
they did like a los Pollos hermanos
activation recently for the release of
better call Saul they do some really
cool stuff um check it out download post
mates use codes Jenna Julian forget the
hassle and waiting in line and get post
mates also guys whatever you're doing
with your toothbrush it's not right
because quip is the right way to brush
your teeth we all want nice clean breath
and the key to oral health is good oral
habits okay quip is the new electric
toothbrush backed by a network of over
10,000 dental professionals that packs
just the right amount of vibrations into
an ultra slim sleek looking model of a
toothbrush that makes honestly brushing
pretty sexy
let quip do the thinking for you when it
comes to your teeth Oh rad well
seriously if you love at first brush and
at the fraction of the cost of the
bulkier electric toothbrushes on the
market right now you also don't have to
worry about getting new brushes because
they send you new brush heads on a
regular schedule with their subscription
it comes with a mouth that goes right on
your mirror with no charger or wires so
equip is compact and light and you can
also travel with it very easily I love
the idea that you can brush with the
same brush at home that you do when you
travel so you don't have to like take a
shave you brush on the road and right
now guys it starts at just $25 for a
nice modern electric toothbrush so that
works and you get a free refill pack
when you get your electric clip
toothbrush when you go to get quip
that's GE tqu IP comm / - no Julian go
to that URL or click the link in our
description and you get started right
away and you get a free refill back if
you use that URL check it out I feel
like you might like okay thank you guys
thank you sponsors Thank You sponsors
correct okay are you ready I am ready
let's do this so use my son sign is a
Virgo obviously we all knew dad was so
excited for this all right son in Virgo
it is rare to find the stereotypical
nitpicky exacting clean freak in modern
day virgos although the sign of Virgo
has evolved with the times there are
some unmistakable traits that remain
Virgo people are generally respectable
hard-working individuals who have a lot
of knowledge and know-how
virgos symbol the Virgin shows itself in
the lives of virgos through a love of
all that is natural and a certain purity
of spirit that keeps virgos
self-sufficient and self contained at
least on the surface virgos are
sensitive to their surroundings they
tend to embarrass easily they are
generally written oh my god I don't know
what that word is
when faced with anything or anyone new
true however once I feel comfortable
they can talk up a storm many Virgo Suns
are not too comfortable in the limelight
these types are just fine living in the
background as long as they feel useful
and appreciated Solar virgos have a
strong sense of responsibility even when
they've convinced themselves to be
irresponsible about something or the
other they worry about it not all virgos
are workaholics however when the Sun
solar
solar virgos are not involved in some
kind of project there's generally a
vague feeling of discontent even when
their lives are filled up with work they
are restless and somewhat nervous
creatures the fear of underperforming is
often strong virgos want to do things
well some are exacting and thorough and
those virgos who have convinced
themselves to do less than perfect job
will generally feel incomplete there's
an odd combination of the intellectual
and the practical in Virgo that is
sometimes mistaken for coolness in fact
virgos are often self-efficacy and shy
they'll brush off your compliments
quickly and sometimes critically but
don't let that fool you they need your
respect and appreciation in fact the
happiest Virgo god this is so [ __ ]
much spot in fact the happiest virgos
are the ones who feel appreciated and
useful and plenty of worthwhile projects
to keep them busy and virgos can
sometimes be of the sweetest kindest
people around
hold on Kevin and just like okay so your
your your biggest critic by far like
will spend hours and hours and hours and
I was working on a video for you and it
would come down to it you would be like
I don't think this is right I don't
think we did this right yeah you're like
criticizing it every step of the way
meanwhile it's [ __ ] great you're
easily embarrassed are you kidding me
you guys there so quickly all of the
dumbest things like people are
commenting you're like I'm so
embarrassed it's adorable
there was one more thing that oh you're
[ __ ] hard to compliment look at the
compliment you just criticized my
compliment you're like wait a minute no
no no that's
stop looking judging me B no like this
is those both all three of those are
very attractive and two of them are
adorable traits tight Virgo ascendant
Sagittarius
but that mean I don't know my [ __ ]
moon is that my moon it just says Sun
and IX which is Virgo but it said Virgo
ascendant Sagittarius I can't understand
hopefully you understand if you know
what this means you have a deep need to
understand the world around you you have
high ideals and you have your eye on
what's on the horizon you're looking
ahead and at times that can seem quite
restless you're proud of your knowledge
and of your morals be sure to avoid
self-righteousness and your enthusiasm
to share your knowledge when used
correctly you are tolerant adventurous
and a curious person and you want to see
the best in people and life conjunction
Sun mercury because your ego and your
mind are aligned you possess much mental
energy you are always in a position to
think about what you want and in many
ways this is an interruption of the will
you are highly intelligent with a great
drive to communicate with others you
invest a lot of pride in your
intellectual capabilities you may not
always listen as well as you speak
however you might be too busy thinking
about what you want to say next but you
are very curious and although you enjoy
expressing yourself you usually dominate
you usually don't dominate conversations
completely as far as studying or
learning goes you are better off reading
the material than listening to a teacher
these traits come from a strong need to
take an active role in communications it
is very hard for you to passively listen
and absorb information your opinions are
usually strong and you are an
independent thinker you tend to be proud
of your opinions and thoughts and might
easily get a bruised ego if you are not
heard if your opinions are pushed aside
or ignored or your opinions are
criticized I think anyone would have a
bruised ego if their opinions are pushed
to Saturday you are expressive and
possibly a very animated speaker you
were also very witty and others enjoy
your playful and sometimes mischievous
sense of humor mic drop I disagree with
one of the things in there that it says
you're not as good at listening as you
are at talking you're like the best
listener I've ever met you're that's cuz
I went to school basically yeah
maybe that's why you are enterprising
and have powerful stores of energy that
you can draw upon when needed you
respond to problems or challenges with a
spirited and enthusiastic confidence
that is admirable you are naturally
competitive and this trait is generally
well received by others because it is
unenforced unaffected and sincere you
truly believe in Fairplay and you seem
to be in love with life what you are
expressing competitive when you are
expressing competitiveness and courage
it's easy for others to smile and accept
these traits as positive ones rather
than being rubbed the wrong way you have
a good physical vitality although
competitive you are not naturally
combative you may enjoy sports or sports
or games that are competitive but not
sorry it competitive is like 12 times in
this era not violent yes I like forts
that are competitive and not violent
that's why jiu-jitsu is not the sport
for me did you see is not violent and I
think they're open well you black out
isn't violent I think there are plenty
of virgos who's breaking the rules of a
competitive game is particularly
upsetting to you yes oh that's why you
hate playing games with your brother
he's always bending the rules yeah but I
also I was also that kid in sports
though that was like I'm not gonna break
any of the rules like I will tell UMP or
whatever you know like if I thought that
something was wrong or whatever you know
if they like did he touch you with their
glove and I'm like yeah he did and my
coach is like [ __ ] why did you lie like
I'm was out hello it's against the rules
that was out thinking I have a paragraph
that has scared of authority okay
breaking the rules of a competitive game
is particularly upsetting to you you are
more than able you are more able than
most to control your desires aggressions
and instincts you know how to be fair
and you expect others to be fair as such
sneaky behaviors uncontrollable impulses
violence and rage are offensive to you
yes y'all better follow the [ __ ]
rules
opposite opposition Sun Jupiter although
your intentions are generally good you
are given to overdoing things you can
easily gloss over realistic details and
get yourself into debt over indulge in
pleasures such as food and drink okay
maybe
but not dead [ __ ] and promise more than
you can deliver for the most part you
can find yourself you can find help for
your excess somebody's there to bail you
out as plenty of people believe that
your heart is in the right place
generally this is the case but excessive
behavior that becomes a pattern you
might usually continually face light
consequences there is a danger you will
not learn from your mistakes and abuse
the system relying on your friends and
family to help you out a little too
often your reputation for being good
people thus can eventually be used to
further your purposes something that
should of course be avoided nothing
about geez however many people are the
most independent [ __ ] person however
many people with this aspect don't fall
into the trap of losing their sincerity
or january's helpful and charitable
still the tendency to live beyond your
means is a real threat that you might
struggle with much of your life that's
terrifying another thing to watch for is
depression you tend to go through
periods of hot intense highs when you're
excessively optimistic these periods are
so marked that they seem to be unnatural
and a fall seems to be inevitable you
can make promises that you intend to
keep but have a problem with
follow-through self-control can be a
real problem try to avoid gambling
altogether damn you're good at gambling
yeah and I'm also like I'm cool stopping
yeah sure usually quite knowledgeable
and generous with your time you have
many talents that you might take for
granted I should avoid gambling
altogether good your identity rides ok
Square Sun Uranus your identity rides on
your sense of personal freedom it can be
quite a challenge to get you to do what
you don't want to do simply because you
see any attempts by others to push you
in a certain direction is threatening to
your sense of freedom you are a very
dynamic person who questions tradition
and authority yet paradoxically you can
be quite set in your ways although a
humanitarian many ways you can be a
little brusque when it comes to
sentimentality or what you perceive to
be excessive attachment to the past or
tradition you can have a lot of nervous
energy and defensive myths it can be
difficult
hold a nine-to-five job or develop
steady routines you work best when you
can manage your own schedule and work in
spurts accurate when you are hit with
creative inspiration you are capable of
tremendous efforts like your
quintessential line right there
however you can be quite temperamental
and it's very hard for you to pour your
heart and soul into something that you
don't feel for it oh my god so true
you don't like superficiality or
pretense which is an admirable trait
however your disdain for pretense can be
problematic in a world where people are
expected to perform whether they are
inspired or not you should try your best
to channel your high levels of intuition
inventiveness and spiritedness into
creative endeavors or important causes
you might find that you encounter much
less resistance in day-to-day life this
way that one's in a room in a way like
super accurate like you you preach about
like you know being like an honest
person and especially like online you be
yourself and you don't like pander or
whatever so when that happens around you
I can like that's something that bothers
you
mmm Square Sun Lilith you might worry
about a friend betraying you although
your partner will undoubtedly find this
person full of charm that's all that
says what the hell moving on Square Sun
ascendant she can face conflicts in life
due to a predict projection of character
that doesn't match what is on the inside
misrepresentation of the self is
frequent for [ __ ] sake okay she must
strive to understand how others perceive
her and work on presenting a more
accurate persona to the world or she
would rub people the wrong way or feel
unrecognized or misunderstood I think
that's true a like six years ago I need
you yeah when I was like doing all of
the it was a lot of talking loud voices
a lot of swearing and what forced me to
get to like the point where we are now
on YouTube was like when I was meeting
people they were doing that thing we
like hey [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] out
yourself [ __ ] funny [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I'm like who do people think that I am
yeah like that I think that that was
very accurate sentence of who I used to
be a teacher Wow not like not that I was
intentionally trying to be something
that I
but since it was such a condensed forced
entertaining sort of environment mm-hmm
I felt like it was sub misrepresentation
of me the moon represents the emotional
responses unconscious predestination and
the self-image all right my moon is in
Aquarius moon in Aquarius people are
extremely observant there are lifetime
students of human nature loving to
analyze why people do what they do this
often stems from a detached even shy
personality especially in youth oh my
god this [ __ ] little Jenna - it's the
album every side meets whether due to a
character or condition conditioning moon
and aquarius people often grow up
feeling different although rather
sociable they're often loners at heart
many have strong egos or at least
powerful defense mechanisms and most
lunar Aquarians will do their best to be
the most unique and unusual person that
can be their inner feeling of loneliness
that they don't quite fit in puts them
on the outside looking in this is very
idealistic and progressive streak in
lunar Aquarians is admirable indeed
however when the moon is in Aquarius
natives often will deny the more
irrational qualities of emotions such as
jealousy possessiveness and fear in an
effort to be above what they consider
pettiness so that's saying like you're
out like in general you have an effort
to make yourself above being petty yeah
I guess that's I'm not sure what that
sentence means I'm a little confused
some of this is like very confusing yeah
well some of it's also like there's some
typos and stuff in here that make it
kind of difficult to read when this goes
too far lunar Aquarians can be
emotionally blocked distance and
detached lunar Aquarians can be willful
especially in childhood with age these
natives generally learn to handle their
strong needs their desire for
independence is powerful indeed no
matter what their age with a quiet son
and or ascendant their desire to shock
others is not always apparent until a
relationship becomes comfortable they
are generally proud of their family
members boasting just how unique they
are when their families are
ultra-conservative but the boast will be
that they rebelled against all of that
your
proud of your family pressure you're
very proud of your family although given
to temper tantrums and willful behavior
in youth moon in Aquarius people often
grow up feeling that messy emotions are
unappealing they often pride themselves
and being cool-headed detached and above
what they consider those base emotions
in the process they can end up
alienating others and themselves
although lunar Aquarians can be
especially adept at understanding others
behavior and motivations they can lose
touch with their own simply because they
have identified too strongly with what
they aspire to be and those aspirations
are often superhuman the Aquarian
tendency to be a human humanitarian
shows that powerfully in moon in
Aquarius however their kindness and
concern for others is generally more a
broad philosophy of life with people
close to them moon in Aquarius natives
can seemingly lack compassion as they
often fully expect others to be as
independent as that and detached as they
are in close personal relationships
however lunar Aquarians generally give a
lot of other a lot of personal freedom
and they will tolerate and enjoy all
kinds of idiosyncrasies in the
idiosyncrasies in people around them
moon and aquarius people are rarely
flighty people but they can be
unreliable when it concerns the little
things in life often this is simply an
assertion of their independence and the
long haul however they are rather
constant as Aquarius is a fixed sign as
long as they have their own space and
the freedom to be themselves however
kooky that may be they're trustworthy
and loyal lunar Aquarians didn't really
make wonderful friends the point they'll
make a point of leaving nobody on the
outside many will fight for others
rights or in crusade for equality what
may be surprising is that moon and
Aquarius people have a lot of pride in
fact they have been attacked if they've
been attacked in any way especially
regarding their character they can
become very inflexible and cool it can
be difficult to know just how sensitive
to criticism lunar Aquarians are simply
because they hide it so well when their
character or behavior is being
criticized they tend to dig in their
heels and keep right on doing it these
things that's like being reactive to it
they fully react others we fully expect
others to accept them
luckily as they are or they don't have
much use for them in their lives these
sometimes mattingly maddeningly
maddeningly for [ __ ] sake thank you
unpredictable people are nevertheless
quite charming they have an unmistakable
stubborn streak and when they left to be
themselves they make unusual and
endlessly interesting people to be
around life wouldn't be the same without
lunar Aquarians unusual spin on the
world and people in it short description
sociable intelligent lucid thanks to
great sociability she has many friends
she is modern original inventive
nonconformists and brings new life
everything that she [ __ ] does brings
weakness weakness she is eccentric with
sharp mood swings complex love life is
it complex helicopter needs
yeah it's complex is you have two other
men in your life mob was in common
that's right I know they're all cannot
well how much time we have left here not
very much moanin to I skipped like
towards the end there was just kind of a
lot of convoluted yeah paragraph so just
pick what you want honestly and then we
have our duel chart thing very ingenious
and inventive we're earning money is
concerned moves around Restless when it
comes to money you can be generous and
frivolous and your spending habits one
day and frugal the next you can be quite
afraid of being in debt and need to feel
that bills are paid in order to feel
secure and safe proof this is likely
also true of savings as you fear being
without still there are times when you
can spend impulsively on a whim and this
is likely when you are feeling
emotionally frustrated you may also hold
on to people quite tightly vanity can be
an issue if you are often looking for
admiration you can be quite dependent on
others for positive feedback until you
learn to develop your own feelings of
self-worth
you're not as emotionally as responsive
as most people you calling me a dead
fish you tend to hold back and wait
before expressing yourself and when you
do it is with the liberation that's that
sense is strong right there yeah yeah
you don't yeah you don't you not want to
like
give quick feedback or whatever it's
like you're gonna take in all the
information that's available and then
you're gonna really give your
perspective on things which is good
because you're like thorough about it
for sure and the whole vanity can be an
issue like I feel like as a younger
person I knew that about myself that's
fair I think vanity can be an issue is a
sentence that could apply to everybody
for sure but like I totally agree with
that like yes a younger person I really
I was wrapped up in this idea that like
you know I needed to look a certain way
you know
well it's interesting to apply some of
this to you now but also you a couple of
years ago because this hasn't changed
you you know in the place sextile moon
Uranus Beach
she is imaginative and has the moon's
intuition completed by Uranus's
independence and originality her life is
out of the ordinary with lots of changes
and a great knowledge of the world not
to reading but through personal
experience
she likes the sensational new things she
acts instinctively but fortunately has a
good sixth sense she likes to be
surrounded by original people artists
mm-hmm this okay trine moon is in Lilith
this aspect favors romantic and sexual
relationships giving charm intrigue and
intelligence emotions are big dark and
mysterious but to embrace these things
instinctively understanding and
accepting the many sides and
complications to your feelings sextile
Moon ascendant she has good influence on
the family which loves and helps the
person she helps
she likes traveling movement change she
likes contact and is open to other
people mm-hmm mercury in Libra usually
quite diplomatic and tactful she
evaluates and ways things up endlessly
often to the point of indecisiveness
I'd say that's one of Rome's favorite
traits that I have what good judgment
she expresses herself clearly before
coming to an opinion on a subject she
listens to the opinions offered by
various people and can compare them
before making up her own mind mental
affinity in her relationships is
paramount she is good at compromising it
always tries to put herself in others
shoes some mental laziness I have some
mental laziness
mercury in IX which is Virgo her thirst
for knowledge is never satisfied she is
full of mental activity she undertakes
exhaustive studies always studying for
pleasure likes journeys to faraway
places and can go live abroad you love
just information yeah isn't this the
same as yours you are externally curious
and hunger for knowledge you enjoy
studying and learning and not do it
don't don't do it because you have to
but because you want nothing a similar
mercury in virgo is this is the same
paragraph as yours hmm okay that make
sense
sextile mercury saturn she strives to be
mentally organized she was able to study
concentrate focus often has the patience
to work towards the goal slowly but
surely she takes time to get
communications just so who intends to
pervert step-by-step directions respects
tradition in rules that's accurate
square mercury Neptune she makes errors
of judgment and lacks sincerity she lets
things happen and is happy in her dream
world confronted by reality she is
hesitant incapable of being tests hope I
don't who is that [ __ ] I don't know her
I don't know her either Venus in Scorpio
Venus in Scorpio people attract others
with their intensity and willingness to
commit they have a strong and
concentrated manner which suggests their
feelings run deep their actions in love
tend to promise deep commitment and
sexual pleasure even if they are not
telling you this directly there are
appeal lies in their focus on you and
their dedication Venus in Scorpio seems
fearless when it comes to intimacy
potential lovers get the feeling that
Venus and Scorpio will never stray that
they are intensely loyal to the one they
love they possess you and somehow make
it seem attractive to be possessed Venus
in Scorpio natives give you their
complete attention these people are very
focused on their partners depending on
your personality you may find this
unnerving or entirely flattering they
have a strong need to control their
partner although this won't be
immediately impaired apparent and they
may not ever admit to this their body
and soul love and commitment can be so
intense that it eclipses fun
and makes loving them a very heavy
experience oh this is their emotion and
intensity may seem overdone to those
looking for a more lighthearted
relationship these people take things to
extremes and can be very provocative
although they want to explore all of
your nooks and crannies they won't
always be forthcoming with their own
when you've upset these lovers you'll
know it depending on the moment Venus
and Scorpio will shoot you in one of the
most piercing glares around or totally
blow up whichever style they choose a
slighted Scorpio lover
is not a pretty sight these people can
be jealous of all your attachments but
few will admit it
they will not they're not afraid of
being underhanded in matters of the
heart they are experts at cutting
through all the fluff and seeing you for
what you are still you may find their
conclusions about you skewed and
mistrustful pleasing Venus in Scorpio
wait oh yeah I'm a Venus I'm dumb
involves demonstrating your complete
commitment and loyalty to them
appreciate their guts when it comes to
love and intimacy they're proud of their
courage in these matters if you can
they're deserving relinquish some of the
control over the relationship let them
let them feel they own you without
taking it to the extremes remember
though that some Venus in Scorpio lovers
can and will take advantage of you on a
subtle level if only to keep you all to
themselves let them have their secrets
and their silences a short description
said - will impassionate passions run
hot and cold full of ardor and desire
where the partner needs to be able to
match her level can be jealous and
possessive
if disappointed or deceived in love she
can become bitter usually very loyal all
pretty spot-on mm-hmm I'm not jealous
and possessive but I'm sure you could
[ __ ] make me it's possible I have a
Mars in Capricorn a Venus and X her best
years are in her parental home but also
in the last years of life so mine's the
same as yours that's what mine said -
jeez Louise
I have a Mars in Capricorn and I have a
sex tile Venus and Neptune her
professional life is on
stable for [ __ ] who is that [ __ ]
YouTube D monetizing oh it's real she
has a taste for the arts as a dreamer is
influenced and romantic she is I am not
easily influenced
she is emotional and very sensitive I am
sensitive romantic creative gentle and
adaptive you naturally express the finer
qualities of mysterious and dreaming
Neptune in your love relationships yeah
her emotional and sex life is powerful
and rich she out she lives out truly
passion passionate love affairs affairs
would you call this a passionate level
of dark you're passionate you're very
passionate it's funny how some of them
are like pretty pretty true and some of
them aren't yes I'm really off but the
ones that are on are like [ __ ] dude
Jesus I don't know you also have to tell
me in the comments if you know any any
more of this that might be true or not
you oh my square Jupiter says she will
ruin herself in order to please her
partner on a sexual level she would go
to a considerable effort to please her
partner in order to possess the partner
more she will ruin herself financially
to get whatever the partner might want
in spite of all that the partner will
never entirely be satisfied she will be
very disappointed in love that's dark
what the hell why didn't you lien have
any ominous [ __ ] in his brush I had some
ominous [ __ ] I had some awful [ __ ] I
also skipped some Amish this says I
usually have lots of children to find
children
oh yeah define children okay yeah my
sextile Mars and Jupiter says she was a
good sense of organization Gees jovial
Frank and sincere she is full of
dynamicism and overabundant energy she
loves life and takes all of it that it
has to offer she likes sports and the
outdoor life she is successful
professionally and emotionally but you
just said it was unstable who's telling
the truth here which one of y'all
planets is telling the [ __ ] truth and
then it says she usually has lots of
children though [ __ ] [ __ ] dog should we
get to the dual charts or not yeah I'm
ready for double check compatibility
alright so we basically we put our two
charts together because it gives you an
option for compatibility charts so we'll
go through these and end it off
interplanetary aspects the following
aspects between planets concerned the
possible relationships between two
charts especially emotional and romantic
relationships but also aspects on social
intellectual and spiritual levels Jenna
in conjunction with Julian Moon Venus
positive aspect they get on each they
get on together very well be it on the
intellectual or emotional level they
love to be together and appreciate each
other's company oh wait always Jenna
conjunction and Julian moon Pluto
positive aspect an uncontrollable great
passion which might be a nuisance as it
sometimes lacks thought or control
jealousy possessiveness absolute need of
the other's presence 24 hours out of 24
can be can be issues wait who has that
near you Jenna's conjunction with Julian
Haley yeah however when Trust is in
place they both will appreciate that
their relationship is growth oriented
and far from lifeless a lifeless routine
their feelings for each other will
evolve over time and they learn from
each other on an emotional level at
every twist and turn this fact is a
treasure
they love the love they share is
transforming in nature so that they both
feel renewed almost like they are new
people through the relationship jeanna
conjunction with julian mars jupiter
positive aspect this is an excellent
excellent aspect they boost each other's
confidence and fill each other with
enthusiasm and make plans together
that's right and I forced you to meet
those plans though we make them together
these are realistic enough to fulfill
jenna square moon
square Julian moon Pluto challenging
aspect great physical or emotional
attraction passion is sometimes
uncontrolled with possible
possessiveness jealousy or emotional
suffocation they must learn to let go
sometimes to allow the other some space
without worry if this relationship ends
it can be very difficult to get over
this relationship if it is possible to
get over it as one or both feel burned
by the other genic conjunction Julian
Mars Neptune the positive aspect there
is an ability to bring imagination and
fantasy successfully into the
relationship while interactions can be
hard to define at times you help refine
one other's outlook there is an element
of mystery that attracts you to one
another some laziness might be
stimulated between you two however
positive aspect favour favourable for
union linking originality to initiative
and decision-making you encourage one
another to be inventive and open up new
possibilities the sexual connections
tend connections tends to stay dynamic
fresh and exciting believe all of that
I'll bleep it out Julian square Julie
Jenna square Julian Jupiter Saturn
challenging aspect he's on the floor
Bobby the two may be too different to
complement each other well but they have
a lot to teach one another if the
individuals are open to learning there
can be difficulties as the Jupiter
person seems too much of a risk taker or
- what does that mean went on want-want
on in their approach to the world while
Saturn persons may appear too cautious
an extra every should be taken
understand the risk taker and who's the
cautious I wonder Jenna conjunction
Julian moon Saturn positive aspect they
can lead their lives together with the
moon often bringing fantasy to Saturn
who sometimes is too austere but whose
other qualities which the moon does not
possess are appreciated to people whose
difference in character is made to
complement each other I like that this
is a good aspect to have her long-term
compatibility and living together
mmm-hmm jenna square julianne mercury
Neptune challenging aspect this
relationship can somehow encourage
illusions and disappointments that
follow these two people can have a hard
time understanding each other and if
they end
cyst on living together the little
deceptions or lies add up and undermine
the relationship it is important to be
clear and clear up misconceptions I feel
like that's oscillate when we first met
it's like when you first move in with
someone you have to like learn how to
yeah you with them all and tell them
information yeah yeah but there's no
lies or deception no it's literally just
like tell me what the [ __ ] you're
planning on doing this week so I know
tell me what the [ __ ] is going on no
challenging aspect their community
styles are very different so that there
are many misunderstandings and
annoyances arising from how things were
said what was said and what was not said
it can be challenging to solve problems
together without getting into an
argument you love us a good meta
argument about what we said and when we
said it it might be best to think things
over separately before turning to each
other for a support their positive
aspect it's love at first sight it's
great passion they will be drawn to each
other like two magnets they will always
have to see and touch each other very
good sexual understanding typically very
much yeah if he said that this type of
relationship may not last forever it may
develop into a quiet and tender love if
they part it is close to impossible to
stay friends because of the constant
reminder of the passion that once
existed yeah but I feel like that's like
kind of a blanket statement they're like
anyone who's penny to people were
passionate it's getting kinda hard state
Jenna Julian's Jenna square Julian Mars
rightness these sentences are so hard to
read a more challenging aspect they
might make each other impatient and
easily fresh foreach other the sexual
attraction is unique and powerful at
first seeming to arise suddenly and
unexpectedly however it is temperamental
attraction and can leave just as
suddenly erratic responses to each other
Jenna sextile Julian Jupiter Uranus
positive aspect this union can be
favorable if the two mutually respect
each other
they both like their independence their
freedom of thought and action the
relationship may be marked by distinct
philosophical interests and unusual
ideas or belief systems which are
ideally encouraged in one another these
there can be nice meetings of the minds
on bigger issues Jenna shrine Julian
mercury
a positive aspect if mercury is looking
for a mother-in-law sorry a mother or
father in the spouse they then this
aspect is very favorable Saturn will
give a lot of intellectual level in in
life in general a little confusing but I
kind of get it
Dennis exile Julian Jupiter Pluto
positive aspect a possible union your
belief systems change and evolve as a
result of your relationship there is a
potential for deep understanding of one
another's goals and approach to life you
challenge one another they grow change
and improve you may feel that you're
able to face life's challenges through
your union hi welcome live to Kermit
Kermit has popped his knee out of its
socket oh honey you straightening out
keep going good boy you got it nice
you're tired I didn't see if it popped
back in or not
sorry guys in or out you didn't even do
anything
this has been a long podcast I'm gonna
pop my knee out real quick
Jenna exiled Julianne Venus Jupiter
positive aspect this union is likely to
be completely successful a couple that
is happy to be alive and to live
together with a pleasant family and home
total confidence in each other and with
a reason that's with the intellectual
understanding similar tastes there is a
strong desire to make each other happy
you enjoy each other's company immensely
and put each other in a happy mood you
make each other left and feel very open
loose and jovial around each other
forgiveness and graciousness
characterizes your partnership whoever
wrote that knows what the [ __ ] is up I
like that one
Genet Ron Julien Jupiter Neptune
positive support aspect the potential
union this is unlikely to be a
determining factor defining factor and
compatibility so you need to look at the
other aspects this is a supportive
aspect chonus exile julian saturn uranus
positive aspects favorable union linking
invention and originality with common
sense and thoughtfulness they might do
great things together
Genesis out Julian Jupiter Neptune the
last one positive supportive aspect a
potential union this is unlikely to be a
determining factor and compatibility si
needs to look at the other aspects this
is a supportive aspect I like this
mm-hmm
I really like this this one I've heard
that before though that someone had said
that because my moon was in something
that I forgot which I now known as
Aquarius that it means that we would get
along because I appreciate you silliness
yeah I feel like it gives more of an
understanding as to just more than just
very whatever yeah yeah I do feel like
it's crazy like you'll have to tell us
too because I don't know how to reset
know how this works like if everything
means because some of them are so
spot-on
and some of them I'm like I don't
understand what this where that came
from
yeah well I mean it's it's hard to think
that they would be completely 100%
accurate with everything that you're
yeah or like if some of them have
because I know I think you're obviously
your Sun Sign is your Sun Sign but that
your moon is also like relatively
important but then which of the planets
are like more important or less
important or if that's the thing or I
don't know yeah I feel like you guys
might be able to shed some light on some
of those points but but we did want to
just like tell you and give you that
reading because we know we've been
asking for it so much so if you did like
if you wanted to read any of this can we
link this or we can just give you her
yeah I was born at 2:30 p.m. and Julian
was born at what time 11:30 6 a.m. yeah
yeah you can enter it yourself if you
want look that's all the information you
need and I was born in Stanford
California Palo Alto California you were
born in Rochester New York so yeah if
you if you want to get all the
information for your records go for it
we use astrology cafe astrology calm
yeah
that was fun it was fun yeah I would I
would do something I'm interested in
that I never thought I would be
interested in astrology but I am my boys
got a Scorpio moon look at you be job
[ __ ] thank you guys for hanging out and
listening to us read our charts fine you
hope you enjoyed it I hope it has
quenched all of y'all stars all right
charge probably one of the most
progressive broadcasts ever yeah well
you guys thanks for listening have a
wonderful week and we'll see you next
time on a gender Julien podcast
[Music]
[Music]